80 was it let's go oh this arrangement
okay no 960 what's this the Polish is
this also called the orangutang can I
get a quick check on that one openings
check is this also known as just the
orangutang but before it's not as
committal as g4 isn't g4 move what do
you call that rob is it the grab that's
something i haven't played you're just
one move away from getting fools mated
if you play g4 to start beware what
about a 4 a 4 no no I'm sorry 83 what
about be five I do be five and a six
then a four chop chop chop chop and then
is this pond overextended
and play this yeah don't I don't want to
over extend that pond okay well what do
you do now I think this is a good start
right here and I'm in a spa I think
actually one of the earlier live blitz
chess commentary videos i posted to my
youtube channel was with this opening
actually the polish and i think i have
just as much information about this
opening now as I did then because i
think all i referenced was that be for
Bishop b2 and that's that's about it
it's about all i know so knight Knight
f3 i guess there's Knight f3 or f4
Knight f3 but i don't i don't really see
a need to get that out f pawn involved
first Oh what else
c4 think I like c4 here having a bishop
on challenger central pawn okay
okay well what about d4 I think I think
this is right how many viewers would be
considering this not a good idea because
I'm extra obstructing this Bishop but
what I'm looking to do is create on the
other hand an extension point for my
king night so I'm looking to take up
residence on this e5 square and in the
event it's captured I'm able to
recapture and have that pond defended as
a follow-up Bishop d3 rook see one Queen
c2 pointing at this King side I think to
be pretty good now I think c5 is the
move here so I'm going to go with it and
with this change of the structure some
things that I'm thinking about now are
pinpointing that pond maybe or what else
or maybe looking to do what maybe get an
e4 at some point after I get some pieces
pointing at the king queen see to Bishop
d3 but now how to recapture I think this
is the correct direction by rule a rule
of thumb that I've run with is to
capture towards the center unless I have
a good reason not to and in this case I
have a good reason to capture away from
the center because I want my bishop to
see now another important point because
I could add the change of the structure
if I play Queen situ or Bishop d3 and I
might have to contend with a five and
then if I strike with e four then there
might be d for my bishop becomes an
idiot I don't know if I want to do that
to my bishop so I better take into
account in other words the possibility
for these central pushes
for black so I wonder if pushing here is
a right idea or here's a different idea
this move is saying you know what go
ahead you get your Center and in the
meantime what I'm going to do is plant
my night on a five and from a five I
keep under close observation the weakest
pond in this current structure for black
at night on a five what is this really
doing it's putting pressure on this pond
but what more can you say about it you
can say that it is constraining the
Queen in some way and that is a position
you don't want to be in for any amount
of time really as soon as you're in that
type of setup then you you're getting
ready to be deflected let's take this
bishop and I'm going to play here right
now I know I could get my night to a
five there's no rush with that I'm
taking into account what else black
could maybe be running with I'm still
looking at this and I think I want to be
in a spot to play e4 even though it
would give up my bishop I want to make
this central structure that black could
be running with I want to be able to
make it flinch in some way for a second
I was thinking that I would need to
castle and connect my rooks here but I
don't want to do that just yet however
if I castle the others night here let me
do this first I think a five is a good
moment here a5 is a good thing to be
running with them I Brooke is defended
with my night and there you have it it's
a good move
okay or is it we're going to see about
that so 38 seconds i need to do less
talk and more play here my night wants
to play to a five but it can't do that
just yet stopping Knight g4 stuff pig on
the seventh night here's a follow-up or
maybe even night here I'm gonna go with
this instead maybe this maybe queen here
I like stopping the queen from coming
out in this direction and I wonder if
it's a good idea to play f4 and preserve
my Knights position I could be playing
b5 and then here let's get my queen out
this night can't go too far away if pond
push if I do this I end up in a fork so
I think I need to play back here if you
come to g3 I want to keep some minor
piece around here to defend my Kings
side because at any moment it could be
about the bishop night and also the
Queen that could be attacking my king so
I'm actually in anticipation of this
advanced I want to just rear out my
night right away Bishop here I actually
thought about for a second but that's
dropping my rook this night can't go too
far because the pressure I have on the
bishop maybe the bishop does best to go
back and I think night to this square is
a good idea so that if this move is
played I could be occupying f5 with my
night or my bishop the night probably
the one that wants to play here because
once here it gets to d6 and that could
be quite good now this is a nasty pin
and I don't know how black gets out of
it this night is constrained and I think
that this is the tactic of deflection
that we're seeing right now brooke here
i think is best if Knight takes I grab
the bishop and that's actually maybe cuz
I'm controlling this flight square so
now I take this and then
what next I'm going to play here trying
to be sneaky with pawn push pawn push
I'm opposite the King and now i have
sneaky stuff pawn push actually not have
the Queen so it was a tight spot that
black ended up finding themselves in
there and I could do this because
there's no well let's do this instead
there's no moves for the rook or the
bishop the king is running for the hills
another queen is on the scene don't
allow stalemate whatever you do do not
allow stalemate okay went down to just
seconds as usual okay let me go back
here and see how either one of us could
have improved let's see where is the
improvement the Polish opening well
what do you do here I wonder if you
should be trying a 5 here instead of
that like see what I do in response to a
five if i play be five maybe you could
target this pawn in some way here's
another thing that's interesting i think
there's this c6 move think in response
to be 4i think c6 is a good move with
actually an early queen placement to be
six and it becomes very difficult to
have a convenient response to Queen
takes pawn so be aware of this idea c6
Queen b6 and I just know that it could
be very awkward for white to be
defending that threat so just some food
for thought on a different variation a
different way to approach there's a
typical be4 start for white
what else
let's see um yeah I don't know it seems
like there's you should try and take
advantage of this because otherwise it's
turning out into a position where I have
a lot of queenside space so I wonder if
this is actually my best suggestion is
to actually run with that c6 queen bee
sixth line or or try and throw in that a
five advance yeah like maybe here
instead of d5 maybe you can consider a
five striking at this point some way try
and show maybe that this is overextended
a five or an early the earliest point c6
Queen B 6 stuff because once we get to
this I think things are pretty good for
white with that night coming into a 5 or
d4 to put pressure on c6 I think that
could turn out to be very uncomfortable
and I was on the defensive for just a
little bit a5 was a good move because
otherwise this is a liability you're
getting rid of your isolated pond
helping out your rook but I do gain
activity in this direction how about
right here actually instead of trading
rooks maybe you can consider just Bishop
here right now and connect your own
rooks and not not give up control the a
file that's another thing to look into
now I'm now you're on the defensive and
it's very easy to go wrong when you're
on the defensive okay